[Music]
richard sherman's 49ers cornerback is a
member of the nfl players association
executive committee and today is an
important day for the nfl and the nfl pa
because there is a proposal on the table
that the union is taking to its
leadership with the possibility that
there will be a recommendation for the
rank and file to accept a proposal
premised on a 17-game regular season
that's the key point in these
negotiations and the union has been
negotiating based upon 17 games the
question is will the nfl give the union
enough to agree to 17 games i mention
all that by way of background because
there's been some pushback in recent
days regarding the possibility of a 17
game season and we'll let you hear from
richard sherman speaking to reporters
yesterday on the topic of a 17 game
regular season here's richard sherman
players have been more more aware of
player safety and longevity and just
life after football
the league
you know kind of pretends that they're
interested in it pretends that they care
about it you know makes all these rules
fines all these players but then
still proposes to players to play an
extra game and not just 17. they're
really they're really just saying 17 so
that they can get to 18. and so that's
two more opportunities for players to
risk their bodies to put their bodies on
the line and that's that's what's so
ridiculous about it nobody calls them
out nobody calls out the hypocrisy and
i'm i'm hoping that one day you know
people will be brave enough to call out
the hypocrisy of saying hey we really
care about player safety but hey we also
want you to play an extra game put your
body on the line and risk risk your
career
hey look i got a ton of respect for
richard sherman as a player but when he
says things like that it makes my blood
boil well me too we've been talking for
years about the disconnect between
playing more football and preserving and
enhancing player health and safety of
course it's hypocritical yeah it's
obviously i don't don't act like we
don't have the courage to talk about it
i know you talk about it don't shame us
here's the problem i'm getting mad yeah
go ahead i like it here's the problem
get them the union is negotiating based
on 17 games that ship has sailed how are
we supposed to take up the fight about
the hypocrisy of playing 17 games when
they're negotiating based on 17 games if
you guys don't want to play 17 games you
tell the nfl stick it where the sun
don't shine it's 16 and that's it and if
you want to lock us out over it lock us
out over it then you'll have us even
waving that flag harder of hypocrisy but
how can you say we don't have the
courage to call out the hypocrisy when
you are negotiating based on 17 games
yeah that's uh that's the frustrating
part well said i mean you gotta you're
good you feel good you feel better now i
feel pretty good yeah that was
therapeutic i think yeah you should you
should i'm here i got your back okay i
don't need your back okay fine i think
you do but either way either way i'm i'm
with you first off it bothered me when i
saw those comments too yesterday i did
because i wanted to be a man you know
first off you just can't make blanket
statements like i wish somebody would
out there would be courageous and brave
enough to stand up about the hip hop
like what
like i don't know i know he probably
doesn't like you because you're getting
twitter awards with him every now and
then yeah god forbid i should state very
real and accurate assessments about the
foolishness of players representing
themselves against billionaires yeah
well okay screw me for about to go there
right now right but that's that's quite
unlikely well i know but and then also
within that i mean gosh mike i'm dead
serious here i don't know a guy on tv
that's more pro player than you are i
mean you really are you're you're all
about it and i know both of us have had
this a lot like how can the nfl talk
about player safety and want to add more
and more than you know add another game
to the schedule i i get it i'm with you
richard we've been pounding the table
there but you're right you know don't
yell at the camera and talk to the media
go back to the nflpa and go wait what
are we doing here this is bullcrap i
mean that's really what it is he's got
to talk to nflpa representatives on the
teams and start to say what are we doing
what are we negotiating because yeah we
are starting to hear players go oh i
can't do 17 games we've got a few guys
this week say that that they don't want
to do it so i don't understand that
either now where i will say i agree with
them is i do agree with them in the fact
that this is a setup it's really to get
to 18. absolutely there's no doubt this
is just a little stepping stone
but that didn't say we're not going to
17. i mean don't say we don't have the
courage to call out the hypocrisy hey
hey richard have the courage to stand up
to the league and say we're not playing
17. forget it it's 16. and if you don't
like it lock us out that's the weapon
that the league has but here's the
problem and this is the fundamental flaw
in the current labor management
relationship between nfl and nfl pa when
push comes to shove the players are not
going to take a work stoppage they're
not going to take a lock out they're not
going to strike they don't want to give
up game checks they don't want to not
play football and they don't have an
alternative to the owners saying fine
you go on strike we'll just get
replacement players they so it's an
uneven playing field and they have to
accept the 17 games but but don't act
like we're we're the problem we're not
the problem no you're negotiating 17
games that's right that's the problem
yeah and if you don't want 17 games then
then say we're gonna tear up the
proposals and we're going back to 16 and
let's stay at 16. and i'd be fine with
that if they do it i am too i'm totally
fine with the way it is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports